these are Arabs and Kurds forced
together because of their joint introd
of the is extremists
Braca was the place where the Islamic
extremists sort of made their capital
city at the moment they're trying to
take hospital the big Hospital in Raptor
they feel they're on the verge bit okay
to see how they're getting on
look at this destruction
everyone kept on saying they're very
close to ending is in in Raqqa and
therefore possibly Syria even though the
Syrian democratic forces moved into the
old city
there are still pockets of
entirely
is huge
there isn't always a very clear front
line in fact it invariably isn't clear
at all rocket had always been billed as
the last stand of Isis it was going to
be where they booby-trapped every every
step that you were going to take was
potentially a booby trap my street every
time they go out you wouldn't be being
honest if you said you're not scared we
tumbled out of the Humvee into a
completely shattered building it was
just rubble everywhere
anything could be booby traps who
literally step over everything do not
physically make contact with it because
you don't know what's wilder you know
opening a door could be wired or a light
switch it was like going up different
stages of anxiety
at the bottom they were sort of drinking
chai and just sort of that was the chill
zone few of the key men in charge had
satellite imagery of the streets where
they were and they would pinpoint where
they thought the extremists were and
then they would call in the airstrikes
these bombs were landing in the next
house yeah literally and they were like
sitting smoking playing games looking at
their phones they were so confident - we
[Music]
only - what - what as he went up it got
more and more anxious all around the
scenes of the fairly major battles until
you got to the top level and people were
hovering in the doorway
[Applause]
you're in there Martin had no shortage
of people they had no shortage of
weapons they definitely felt they were
on the winning side
these are farad's and turds unlikely
allies but forced together because of
their joint hatred of the is extremists
they had a really high motivation and
they weren't scared
urine satyam heightened sense of
adrenaline and fear and excitement and
nervousness
[Music]
I think the longer you work with someone
you started no one how they think what
they think what expected you only have
one chance to get it so everyone has to
be performing at their pop level
by the time you heard a bullet flying by
you you're way too close so you need to
get somewhere else
[Applause]
they had homemade grenades slung around
their neck an ak-47 and their legs to
run forward and a bit of courage things
didn't go according to plan
there were people hurt people killed
[Music]
they've taken point a few injuries and
clearly the Islamic militants are
fighting back the guys on the ground
were all still sort of locked in this
medieval almost type of fighting
bracha was quite surreal because there
were no civilians coming out there was
no you had no sense that you were in a
city filled with people but the
devastation in Raqqa was so complete
that there wasn't an awful lot left
[Music]
they're trying to take a main hospital
in Iraq there may not be very many is
militants left but they're putting up
the stairs within seconds of going in
there was this enormous crash of the way
they're almost desperate to get it over
here and they were saying this is all
gonna be over possibly within the next
year it seemed to us there was no way it
was going to happen that day very
unlikely it would happen that night and
it went on for many more days after that
they were setting up this huge big
recoilless rifle it's not meant to be
fired inside a building it's meant to be
out in a fuel somewhere we finally get
to the point where they're going to fire
it
it's literally definite you can see
anything very quickly because they've
checked up top much of the dust
I thought the walls are gonna fall down
the ceiling is gonna come down they just
felt like everything was rattling their
reaction was the most illuminating thing
they carry did not expect to survive I
[Music]
think there's a massive legacy because
first otters bred a whole generation of
people who feel utterly let down by the
West
[Music]
they feel betrayed there's a whole
section of the world who watched them
suffer and didn't do anything about it
who could have done it could have
intervened and could have saved a lot of
people
[Music]
you've got young people who don't know
anything but war and hatred
[Music]
everything's changed I think as a result
of is I think the whole world has
changed
[Music]
people's tolerance level towards utterly
depraved actions and war crimes seems to
have risen so high I think journalists
in this day and age now where where our
industries under attack so much from
world leaders even who are questioning
our motives and the authenticity of our
reports and what we're doing and why
we're doing it
I think the role of journalists is more
important than it's ever been
[Music]